there's the addition PFT ot the extra
little program where we talk about the
things we didn't get to or we talk more
about the things we discussed and that's
the category we fall into today Chris
Sims because we're gonna talk about this
notion of untradable players it all came
up because the Bengals have suggested
they wouldn't have taken any offer to
move out of the number one overall spot
in the draft and not select LSU
quarterback and Heisman winner Joe
burrow putting him in the category of
untradable before he's ever even touched
an NFL football in an NFL game so
regardless of whether or not burrow is
untradable and I think we both agree
that he isn't untradable at this point
let's come up with the guys who are
let's go back and forth let's start
pulling names back and forth and try to
come up with a consensus list and begin
with the most obvious and then we'll see
how far it goes is it four is it six is
it ten let's start give me give me the
first guy that comes to mind for you
when we talk about an untradable player
Patrick mahomes that's the first guy the
most untrainable guy in the sport I
don't think you're gonna disagree with
that right oh absolutely no disagreement
he is you could not give the Chiefs
anything that would get them to even
consider trading Patrick Holmes I agree
completely and entirely and I think they
what they wouldn't even answer the phone
they would know they don't even bother
don't even have a conversation don't
waste our time
Patrick mahomes is gonna be a chief for
life period now look maybe some point
later in his career if his skills start
to diminish that's a different
conversation for now no way nohow all
right I'll go Russell Wilson
the Seahawks have built their team
around Russell Wilson he's one of the
top quarterbacks in the NFL they've made
the big financial commitment to him I
think Russell Wilson is untradable by
the Seahawks no way no how do they part
ways with Russell Wilson after all
they've invested in him do you agree
with agreed yeah I do I do agree with
that you know one like you said they've
invested them two they've handed over
kind of the keys of the organization and
made it about the offense in Russell
Wilson that's what's different about
this Seahawks team as compared to the
teams that were winning the Super Bowl
so you're right you know between what
they've invested in him and then what
they've invested in the team to make
sure he can carry
team that way too I don't I don't think
he could ever be traded either now
listen I'll say this and I think I've
told you this before I had heard a rumor
for some people that I trusted a few
years ago that you know Seattle called
Cleveland when they had the number one
pick and there was this rumor going
around the NFL that they offered Russell
Wilson and the Browns for the number one
pick a year they drafted Baker Mayfield
I never followed up but I just know I
had people tell me that that was
something people were hearing but now
we're two years down the road three
years down the road and I think the
Seahawks have totally flipped the
organization over to where it is all
about Russell Wilson and yeah he's more
untrainable now and I think he was even
then I don't know how serious those
discussions were but I I agree with you
there I was long story short I think
calling the Browns about possibly
trading Russell Wilson is the equivalent
of Russell Wilson going to spring
training with the Yankees right baseball
was always something he revered when it
was time radio she ate a new contract so
Russell we're getting close to doing a
new contract we're gonna work it out
we're gonna trade you to Cleveland your
choice now he was born in Ohio but I
don't think that's enough to get him to
convince his spouse to live in Ohio oh I
was not in Ohio to I'm not trying to say
something bad about Ohio but that is the
kind of thing that I think a team would
maybe do because I think there may be
something to it and the deeper level is
Russell we got to work this out
reasonably at some point because if you
just want too much we will trade you and
get what we can get and we're gonna put
you in a position where you're gonna
have to be the jerk you know he's so
bright not be so polished it's one thing
for Antonio Brown to put the kibosh on a
trade to Buffalo it's another thing for
Russell Wilson to put the kibosh on
anything what's he going to say if the
Browns want him and the Seahawks are
gonna trade him what's he gonna say I
don't want to go to Cleveland he's not
wired to do that so they really could
have put him in a tough spot Chris I
think there may be something to that
well you know again like I said it's not
that I'm an investigative reporter but
you know we both you know we both know a
lot of people in football you know I do
too and yeah I you know I know back at
the time not long
or I'd kind of told you that when we
heard a commercial break or through text
or whatever it may be and it wouldn't be
shocked I mean I think your points real
the fact that you know they could have
been holding that over him just like a
little bit last year too before he got
the deal right there was those rumors
that all Russell Wilson Ciara they want
to go to New York they might be the new
quarterback of the New York Giants and
all that stuff yeah probably a lot of it
was negotiate Arian employees and
negotiation so but either way I think
we're both in agreement that right now
he is untrainable and I think the next
guy on that list is Lamar Jackson you
know I'm right I mean right now
especially he's the MVP of football and
you know to the same extent we've talked
about the other two guys they've really
formulated an orchestra in the offense
and the team around the skill set of a
Lamar Jackson and yeah if you're gonna
have all these tight ends and great
offensive linemen and the plethora of
running backs you know to run this
intricate you know read-option
offense off of the run game you need a
you need a talent like Lamar Jackson and
they're just they're not growing on
trees we know that so I think he is
untrainable at this point I agree with
you there especially because of all the
changes they made to the organization to
the offense to cater to the strengths of
Lamar Jackson
yeah there's no way the Ravens would
give him up at this point because who's
gonna run the offense if he's gone
Robert Griffin the third no eight years
ago it's funny to think it's funny to
think how that perception changes Robert
Griffin the third but look at what he
got in trade because that that's what
Washington did they didn't trade up for
the number two pick just because they
wanted a number two pick they traded up
to get RG three three first-round picks
and the second-round pick was the total
investment so he wasn't untradable then
Lamar Jackson is untradable now and now
we get to a point where it's harder to
find guys and I'll go with Aaron Rodgers
here because this year he is untradable
because the cap hit would be crippling
for the Packers and I don't think Jordan
loves even remotely ready to take over
they need to have him now between the
cap hit and but and the skill set I'm
willing to put Aaron Rodgers on the list
Chris I think so too I mean he's the
best player on their team that's why I'm
still confused by the drought
let's address our strength of our
football team and draft somebody there
so they can sit on the bench and drink
some Gatorade still don't understand
that pick it actually pisses me off more
as the days go by so but I'm with you I
mean he's he's still one of the best
players in football and I don't think
Green Bay is really you know a great
team without Aaron Rodgers so between
that and the money situation like you
said he might be trainable here sometime
in the future
but he's not in 2020 that's for sure
Aaron Donaldson who died on the list
yeah I think for me right I mean Aaron
Donald you know yes you know just he's
the best defensive player in football
for what is it now five years running
and he's unstoppable
you know all I have to do is you know
when I have my podcasts and things and I
asked you know NFL players who's the
best player they played against and do
things like that
then I asked Aaron Rodgers last year and
he didn't hesitate I mean and then and
then he went on to be like isn't it
unbelievable I mean have you ever seen
anything like Aaron Donald and I I was
like no you're right I mean Aaron Donald
is just rare you know to be that
dominant that's sighs to be that
athletic and twitchy and quick and
explosive and everything about him and
you know he's the best player on the
Rams football team and a lot of the
things and chaos we've seen the Rams
create on the defensive side of the ball
since Shaun McVeigh's got there and made
them a contender
it all goes through Aaron Donald and
Aaron Donald's a game wrecker a game
plan wrecker and you have to spend all
week trying to figure out how you're
gonna stop him and not let him ruin a
football game his n think makes him
untradable of all the contracts the Rams
have meted out over the past couple of
years this is the only one that hasn't
blown up in their faces right this year
right they have to hold on to every bad
decision they've made whether it is
signing Todd Gurley and giving him way
too much money
signing Jared Goff giving him way too
much money signing Brandon cooks and
giving him way too much money then
dumping him two years later trading for
Jalen Rams you without insisting on a
new contract all these bad moves the one
thing that's worked out is Aaron Donald
you can't trade Aaron Donald now
he is the best defensive player in
football and they need to ride that out
as long as they can to make up for all
the stupid stuff they've done Chris and
beyond him I don't know who else who I I
think that's it Mike I don't you know
hey maybe Christian McCaffrey now
because he just got that new deal I mean
I don't know but again I'm with you I
don't know if there's anybody else that
we can legitimately make a case for you
know right now I want to say there yet
who are you gonna say Brady
calimary you're right
it is Kyle Emery good job I you you're
right you're not trading Kyle Emery for
anything right now because right now if
you know you had a look into a crystal
ball you're going oh this guy looks like
he's gonna be really really special and
unlike anything we've seen in the
history of football so yeah you're like
awesome pull by you you're right I think
they'll I think the list probably ends
right there yeah you're right I mean
even Christian McCaffrey if somebody
would call up and offer Patrick mahomes
I mean I guess that's the ultimate test
right would you try out and that makes
calimary tradable cuz Kliff Kingsbury if
he could get him but who knows who knows
maybe no I mean because here's the other
side of it and this is one of the
reasons why the Bengals would hesitate
if the Chiefs did call and offer Patrick
mahomes even though at the end of the
day they should say yes we'll take him
you've got Joe burrow on the front end
of a rookie contract you're stepping
into a major financial obligation if you
take Patrick mahomes that is the one
thing to keep in mind here if the
Cardinals if you're the Bengals if
you're a team that would be in a
position where you could trade a young
quarterback you're not getting Patrick
mahomes in the early years of his career
you're getting him right on the the
brink of really having to pay him huge
money and I still think the Cardinals
would do it I think the Cardinals would
take that I don't now for Kyler Murray
cuz calimary is on the verge of
exploding the way that my homes did in
2018 yeah he's I mean I think they'd
probably take my home but I wouldn't be
easy I don't know if you know I mean
that that's not going with this
of what we're talking about here you're
right package but never be traded under
any circumstances the list begins with
Patrick mahomes and for every other one
of these guys you have to ask yourself
would you trade the guy straight up for
mahomes
would you trade russell wilson for
patrick mahomes I mean to put him on
this list our answer is no would you
trade lamar jackson for patrick mahomes
you put on t you know again I bet that
just underscores yeah how much better
patrick mahomes is then everyone else
right now I think so right now yeah and
again to what you said Mike I mean we're
just we're just starting to scratch the
surface here for this guy you know he
the year he threw for 50 touchdown
passes just two years ago I know many
times I came back and went man he could
have thrown for 60 he just played it a
little conservative and then last year
he got hurt and all that so again I
don't think we've seen the best from
this kid yet that's what's really
awesome and scary and everything about
it and that's why he is the best player
in the game and the guy that you know I
think you and I both enjoy watching more
than any other player in football right
now there's a lot of guys we love to
watch but mahomes is he just got she
does things that we've never seen
players do or quarterbacks do and it's
just fun to watch the theatrics and the
way in a way which he gets it done well
here's hoping that we will see him and
his teammates on Thursday night
September 10 raising a banner hosting a
team game will be played hopefully we're
gonna find out that schedule tonight for
all the Chiefs games but starting with
the opener that will be televised by NBC
let's hope it happens as scheduled Chris
great stuff as always we'll check you
out later today on lunch talk live we'll
check out on button with Paul burmeister
and we'll see you on Monday be a man be
good have a good weekend hi pal
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports